Fox News says the Federal Aviation
Administration is actively recruiting
workers who suffer severe intellectual
disabilities psychiatric problems and
other mental and physical conditions
under a diversity and inclusion hiring
initiative spelled out on the agency's
website the faa's website States
targeted disabilities are those
disabilities that the federal government
as a matter of policy has identified for
special emphasis in Recruitment and
hiring they include hearing Vision
missing extremities partial paralysis
complete paralysis epilepsy severe
intellectual disability psychiatric
disability and
dorismar and inclusion hiring plan which
says diversity is integral to achieving
faa's mission of ensuring safe and
efficient travel across our nation and
Beyond the faa's website shows the
agency's guidelines on diversity hiring
were last updated on March 23rd
um
so this is part of their diversity
efforts is to get in people with
disabilities
now uh In fairness just so that we don't
engage in any clickbait hyperbole here
this doesn't mean that uh United
Airlines or or Southwest is going to go
and hire a blind mentally disabled dwarf
to be a commercial pilot now I
wouldn't wouldn't be surprised if we get
to that point but that's not what this
means at least not yet uh there are a
lot of other jobs in the airline
industry generally a lot of other jobs
in the
FAA and people who defend this policy or
any Dei policy will argue that you know
they they still have the same hiring
standards in place that they always have
so if they hire somebody with a physical
disability or a psychiatric problem that
person is still going to have to pass
all the same tests and demonstrate his
Fitness in the same way as anybody else
which means that if they get the job
then they're
qualified and uh and that's the claim
right that's the Dei defense and in
theory that could be true in some cases
like if there's a job filing paperwork
or whatever at the FAA office there's no
reason why somebody who's hearing
impaired couldn't be perfectly qualified
to do that job so in theory someone who
happens to fulfill a Dei quota doesn't
need to be
unqualified in
theory but if if that's all that was
happening right if they were just
letting anybody apply and and then
hiring the best of that crop um then you
wouldn't need Dei because that was
already the
case okay but like I'm I'm pretty sure
that prior to this Dei standard being
put up on the website or updated in
2022 uh prior to that you know you could
be a hearing impaired person and get a
job filing paperwork at the FAA or what
whatever I mean that was already the
case so when you add in Dei you're
adding in something
extra um and what are you adding in well
the moment you say we need we need to
get more of this sort of person into
these positions right you're looking at
a particular demographic whether it's
disabled whether it's uh black people
whether it's women and you're looking at
demographic saying we we need more of
them specifically you're not saying we
need more qualified people you're saying
we need more of those
people and even if you're saying we need
the most qualified of those people into
this position even if that's what you're
saying which is which which even that is
is not actually like that would be
better that would still be terrible that
that would be better than what they're
actually
doing um but the moment you do that then
you are going to end up lowering
standards because with the current
standards right before Dei whatever the
standards were you had however many
people you had in whatever demographic
right and if you want more of that
demographic the standards are going to
get
lowered that that because because with
the standards up here you had you know
standards up here you had X number of
people in your favorite
demographic so if you want to get even
more then that means the standards are
going down
here and it's insane it's insane on many
levels it's especially insane because um
to begin with if you're looking at the
airline industry and you say well we
don't we have a minority of women or we
have a minority of black people or we
have a minority of disabled people
that's not a problem like why is that a
problem if the ranks are full of people
who are qualified and few of the
qualified people happen to be female or
black or whatever who cares it doesn't
matter doesn't make a difference it's
not a problem that needs to be
solved as long as you're bringing in the
most qualified people whatever the
demographic makeup happens to be at the
end of that doesn't matter it's not a
problem um and so so if if if if no one
is black that ends up in that
um that that you know ends up in that
camp not a problem if you end up with
everyone is black also not a problem as
long as race is not taken into into
account at all and you're just hiring
the best people you know I've been
talking about my Helix mattress for
years Helix is the gift that keeps on
giving every night when I go to bed I'm
reminded of how great they are Helix is
now introducing their newest most
high-end collection Helix Elite Helix
Elite harnesses years of extensive
mattress expertise to offer a truly
elevated sleep experience this
collection off includes six different
mattress models each tailored for
specific sleep positions and firmness
preferences if you're nervous about
buying a mattress online you don't have
to be Helix has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
because why do you want to buy a
mattress that was made for somebody else
you don't so you got to go to
helixsleep.com wolves take their
two-minute sleep quiz and find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type your mattress will come right to
your door for free plus Helix has a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will their financing
options and flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night sleep is never
far away Helix is offering 25 uh% of all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
my listeners go to helixsleep.com Walsh
and use code Helix partner2 this is
their best offer yet and it won't last
long that's helixsleep.com Walsh and use
code Helix partner2 with Helix better
sleep starts now but again that's not
how it goes and uh and here's the CEO of
United making it clear how uh it really
works listen how is diversity and
diversity targets working into the
aviate academy we have committed that
50% of the class of of the classes will
be women or people of color today only
19% of our Pilots at United Airlines or
women or people of color and by the way
from all the data I've seen that's the
highest of any airline in the country
white males don't just dominate in the
cockpits also in the sea suite at United
Airlines well look at United I'm proud
of the diversity that we actually have
in our our sea Suite I think if you look
around Corporate America cor me if I'm
saying though so I this is just based
off your website the people you list as
Executives but out of 11 people three
are women I believe one is a person of
color um that's correct um but you know
in Corporate America I think you know
that's a low bar how do you raise your
own bar well a lot of this is you know
focusing on it we have uh programs to
one of the things we do is for every job
when we do an interview we require women
and people of color to be involved in in
the interview process bringing people in
early in their careers um as well uh and
giving them those opportunities yeah you
know you got to get those white males
out of there right you know the the
white males you know the the people that
um have made air travel into the safest
form of travel that that's ever
existed the form of travel where you're
35,000 ft in the air and going 400
mph and that's the
safest um so and the people who
predominantly who achieve that were
white males and so how do we thank them
let let's get them out of and when I say
that the people who predominantly
achieve that are white males I I'm not
making that up that's the proponents of
Dei are the first to say that like
they're the ones who we're going to look
at and say well historically it's been a
white male dominated field okay so
you're you're the one saying
that okay well also historically what
has this field
achieved those white males who were
dominating the field were they were they
doing poorly was there an issue was
there a problem were they screwing
up
no the people who not only invented
human flight to begin with uh were white
males and then the people who even
according to the the de proponents who
made it unbelievably safe were also
predominantly white males so yeah we got
to get them out got to get those numbers
down this is what we're doing we're
looking at we're saying
okay here's here's a here's an industry
that's doing fantastically well uh has
achieved Feats uh unknown to
mankind what's the demographic
predominant responsible for that let's
single them out and then try to get rid
of
them um and that's what they're doing
now it is
uh it is suicide well I was going to say
it's suicidal but it's not really
because the CEO of United probably isn't
even flying like he's probably flying
private you know he's not backing coach
on a United
flight um so it's not suicidal for
him I bet you he wants to make sure the
people fly in his planes that he's on
are the most qualified uh so no it's not
Su suicidal really uh as far it's
homicidal actually is what it is hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there